Hi, this is Presh Talwalkar. This math problem is being shared around Facebook and one of the recent post has over two million comments.
I've seen this post being shared since December, but for some reason It's getting really popular right now,
and the mainstream media is talking about how this problem is baffling the Internet.
So I wanted to address the problem in this video and discuss what many people believe to be the correct answer.
Can you figure it out?
So we can consider this as a math problem, if you consider the apple, the banana, and the coconut as different variables and not having numerical values.
We'll start out with the first equation that 3 apples are equal to 30.
If we divide both sides by 3, we get the result that 1 apple is equal to 10.
This is generally an accepted part of the problem.
We'll use the information, the apple, in the second equation, and this is where things get a little more debatable.
So the apple is equal to 10...
and then if you look at the rest of the equation, you have 2 different bunches of bananas.
Now some people consider 1 whole bunch of banana as one variable, but I would consider counting each banana separately.
So there're actually 4 bananas in each bunch, so you'd want to count that there are an 8...
...total of 8 different single bananas.
And that equals 18. So we subtract by 10 and then divide by 8 we get the result that each banana is equal to 1.
We now have the equation that 4 bananas minus a full coconut is equal to 2.
So we have 4 minus the coconut equals 2.
We can solve this to get that the coconut is equal to 2.
Now even people who agree up to this point still might have a debate about the very last line,
which is what you're supposed to evaluate.
Because if you look closely there's some differences in our pictures.
We don't have a full coconut, we actually have a half coconut. So the full coconut is equal to 2, then a half coconut would be equal to 1.
So we have 1 for the coconut, we add 10 for the apple, and finally people still get confused at this point because we don't have...
...4 bananas. If you look closely, we actually only have three bananas. So you want to add three at this point,
and you get 1 plus 10 plus 3, and that gives us our answer of 14.
This is what most people consider to be the correct answer.
You could interpret the pictures to be slightly different.
You could say the coconut might be... say 3/4 of the coconut, in which case you get a slightly different answer.
But 14 is what many people consider to be the correct answer.
Thanks for watching this video please subscribe to my channel,
I make videos on math and game theory. You can catch around my blog: MindYourDecisions,
which you can follow on Facebook, Google+, and Patreon.
You can catch me on Social Media @PreshTalwalkar, and if you liked the video,
please check out my books; their links are in the video description